we're going to begin this hour with
oscar-nominated actress turned filmmaker
maggie gyllenhaal who is making her
directorial debut with a movie called
the lost daughter olivia coleman stars
as leida a professor and mother of two
daughters
forced to confront her own past when she
becomes obsessed with another young
mother named nina played by dakota
johnson in this preview nina's daughter
is crying after losing her doll after
also wandering off from her mother
so she's not calming down
[Applause]
it's been a weird day
we found her and then she lost
her doll
[Music]
i used to have a dog like that
called mina
nina mina
but mini mama as my mother called her
and maggie gyllenhaal joins us now
maggie thank you for being here and
congratulations congratulations uh the
the movie is astonishingly good uh
there's a fantastic review out today in
the washington post i think others are
going to be forthcoming and this is your
first job as a director yeah after all
these years as an actor
why at one point did you not think this
was a possibility and how did you pull
it off so spectacularly in job number
one
um
i think
i i think actually i've probably always
been a director
you know in a way and i just didn't
i d there were so few models of women
who were directing when i was young and
i
i mean there were women who did it like
jane campion who's got an incredible
movie out this year and and i was a real
role model of mine but aside from her i
if you were a storyteller and you were
interested in movies when i was young
you were an actress or that's how i did
it anyway like a thinking actress there
were a lot of those yeah you know of all
the the movies that you might have
directed why did you choose this very
difficult and complex and layered and
fantastically popular elena ferrante
novel the lost daughter
well
when i read her books i mean she tells
the truth
you know she tells the truth in a way
about things that i think we've agreed
as a culture not to talk about and she
just breaks the agreement and i think
there's something
inherently dramatic
about telling the truth and especially
about something that's taboo especially
about motherhood
and about just being a woman in general
in the world and you're right about
mother let's talk about motherhood okay
let's do it that's the thing that was so
fascinating to me about because you know
this this woman is clearly struggling
and i wasn't quite sure what the
struggle was about i loved the twist and
the turns you took in it but why did you
make
tony and i were saying do you call it a
thriller but it really is a thriller
this particular movie and the questions
it raises about motherhood and how
frustrating and joyous it can be
i have two things to say about that yes
i do think it's a thriller in a way
that's the kind of structure i hung my
hat on
but i also think
not everyone agrees with me on this but
i think that when women make movies
which we haven't had
all that much opportunity to do
that it looks different and there might
be a different kind of set of genres
that start to come into play
when women are making more movies so
like yeah ours is a thriller but it's
also a lot of other things and it
doesn't just look good also real life
exactly yeah real life it comes from a
very introspective place um
why do you think um there isn't enough
stories told by women and how do we
change that
well because it's expensive to make
movies yeah and so the question is like
what's valuable and i think
i
i grew up not i mean seeing really
interesting movies that had women at the
center of them made by directors we love
that we probably all sitting here would
agree like that's a great movie but
i think if we're honest maybe it showed
just like a portion of our experience
not the whole thing
and so what i was really interested in
trying to do was like get into the edges
of our experience the the real darkness
and the real
ecstatic lightness and especially about
mothering i think we're we got to stay
quiet about all sorts of things and it
makes us think
no one else feels the way we do
and
i felt very comforted reading elena
ferrante the book that this is based on
because i was like oh my god someone's
saying out loud all these things that
i've felt for so long i didn't even know
i felt but high praise from her too yeah
i phrased from her which she said yeah
she liked the whole thing she liked the
whole thing and that you created cinema
can i can i ask about the since we're
talking about experience the experience
of directing
a whole suite of stars but in particular
your husband is in this movie uh and he
plays
i don't know what you wrote in the
script but kind of like the hot
professor
and there's a love scene what was it
like working so close very sultry lovely
very sultry love scene very well done
very well what was that whole situation
like yes i know i cast my husband as the
object of desire
against
an incredibly talented gorgeous bright
young jesse buckley you know
and there was a moment where i was like
maybe that's not such a good idea
but
to be honest with you look i have been
with my husband for 20 years since i was
23 years old we've been through all
sorts of things and i went
my husband loves me
and i love jesse buckley
and i think like i mean olivia
calls her auntie jesse to my kids you
know i trust that woman yeah and in a
way
really yeah the
the physical stuff
it can be strange i guess but really
what makes that scene hot and those
scenes between them hot sense is that
it's it's a connection of the mind
and when someone is very much so is
attracted to your mind
there's nothing hotter that's right i
think that's right i totally agree
maggie gyllenhaal thank you very much
very hot movie it's a thriller it's a
drama i think many awards are going to
be coming your way
nominee and critics choice award nominee
congrats and more to come it's got a
shelf of them already you're going to
have another shelf uh the law starter
premieres in select theaters on friday
if it's in your area i would recommend
you go see it it's also coming to
netflix on december 31st watch it with
your family they'll have an interesting
conversation thanks maggie